Negan was a polarizing character who
entered the Walking Dead Like a Wrecking
Ball After Five Seasons playing him it's
safe to say it turned Jeffrey Dean
Morgan's life upside down Jeffrey Dean
Morgan was a fan of The Walking Dead
series and the comic books before he was
even cast on the AMC hit so when he was
offered the role of Negan it was like a
dream come true Morgan told interview
magazine in 2016 I'd watch the show for
years it was one of the few shows I
would DVR and pay attention to Morgan
always felt his resemblance to Negan
through his love of The Walking Dead
comic series he told interview magazine
that fans started approaching him at
ComicCon and told him that he would be
amazing as a fan fave character when
Morgan's agent told him about the
possibility of playing a mystery villain
on The Walking Dead he knew exactly what
the role was you know what I'm thinking
cuz I have a guess he told interview
magazine it'sing Negan and I'm going to
do it Morgan was determined to be on the
show the actor was working on The Good
Wife when he was cast on The Walking
Dead But did his best to find a couple
of days in his schedule to film the
season 6 finale AMC tried to be careful
about spoilers so Morgan only received
his portion of the script before they
shot the episode he told variety it was
a little bit tense for me it all
happened very fast I think I got the
script two days before I shot it Jeffrey
Dean Morgan has been in his fair share
of movies and TV series some likely know
him as Denny and gr's Anatomy or Ike
Evans in Magic City and some first
noticed Morgan in Supernatural when he
played salmon Dean's father John
Winchester but Morgan's turn as a
comedian in Watchman proved he had the
chops to play a villain despite having
success as an actor Morgan joining the
cast of The Walking Dead in season 7
will begin his longest consistent run on
a television series at New York
Comic-Con in 2022 Morgan revealed the
original plan for Negan was only three
seasons long resembling the character's
original story arc in the comic he
revealed originally it was going to be 3
years I had a conversation with Scott
gimple and it was like you got to be hon
it for at least 3 years if you want to
be a part of the show I was like that
seems like a long time and negan's role
in the series developed well beyond the
comics Morgan stayed on until the series
finale starring in 95 episodes and
spanning seven seasons far from an
industry newcomer Jeffrey Dean Morgan
still wasn't prepared to star in a
series as high-profile as of Walking
Dead Morgan told the New York Times in
2022 I was a big fan of the show and I
knew it was going to attract a bit of
attention but I had no idea of the
levels of crazy that it was going to be
when asked in 2016 how the series had
changed his life Morgan jokingly
admitted to AOL that he needed security
he also describes some strange
interactions with fans who have followed
him home and how he's been a recipient
of odd letters and packages you know I
need to look in my rear viw mirror when
I go home at night from work cuz people
will follow me home I get weird mail
despite having been on popular shows
like Gray's Anatomy the intensified
attention was a big change Morgan told
ABC News in 2017 I'm a very private dude
I live in the middle of nowhere so it's
been an adjustment he also told AOL
everyone told me when I showed up on the
set for the show that my life was going
to change and I thought well that's bull
but Morgan later realized that the role
was Far different than anything had done
before he told Men's Journal in 2021
that being on the series and the success
of his wife Hillary Burton's
best-selling Memoir roal Diaries helped
him realize there wasn't a lot he could
hide anymore he explained how freeing it
was calling it quite quot a weight off
my shoulders Jeffrey Dean Morgan's
contentious entrance Into The Walking
Dead didn't necessarily make him popular
with longtime fans some fans even
stopped watching the show after the
season 7 premiere when Negan killed fan
favorite character Glenn played by
Steven young Morgan told Insider in 2023
that one scene changed my life literally
in so many ways and I still get for it
he added that fans still reminds him
that Glenn was their favorite character
so much so that Morgan told Insider in
2022 that but if he could change one
thing about Negan he revealed I wouldn't
have killed Glenn
what was the joke that bad being such a
memorable character made Morgan's face
pretty recognizable and hanging out with
other stars from the ultra popular
series only compounded his notoriety
Morgan recorded an experience with
co-star Norman readers while they were
riding motorcycles together he told
interview magazine within 3 minutes of
us stopping to get gas a couple of phone
calls that people make and there's 100
people blocking us and we can't get out
Morgan told AOL that Rus is especially
generous with fans and that he has
learned a lot about being gracious from
his coaster when Jeffrey Dean Morgan
first landed the role of Negan Walking
Dead co-creator Robert Kirkman was still
working on the character's backstory
Morgan told variety after his debut in
the season 6 finale hopefully we'll find
out more about Negan as we go I think
his backstory is going to be pretty
fascinating the backstory was finally
explored when Morgan's real life wife
Hillary Burton joined the cast for one
episode of the war Walking Dead in
season 10 to play Negan to ce's wife
Lucille Morgan and Burton met through
their friends Jensen and denil akles in
2009 after welcoming two children the
couple tied the nut in 2019 although the
two actors worked on the same series
extent in 2015 they didn't share any
scenes so working together as Negan and
Lucille was their first time acting
together face to face Burton gush about
working with her husband on The Walking
Dead in an Instagram post saying when I
tell you it has been a joy I'm saying it
with tears in my eyes Morgan also posted
to Instagram saying working with his
wife was a highlight of his career AMC's
The Walking Dead wasn't afraid to put
complex characters on screen initially
Jeffrey Dean Morgan had reservations
about playing a vengeful character like
Negan he told Men's Journal in 2021 I
was worried that Negan was very
two-dimensional I felt like every scene
was an iteration of him coming out of
that winner Bago but Morgan admitted
that he saw Negan as more of a Survivor
he told Variety in 2016 I didn't think
of him necessarily as a villain Morgan
had to dig deep for the character's
redeemable qualities but acknowledged
that some fans believe Negan is
psychotic the actor has another way of
seeing his character telling variety I
never looked at him like that I think
there's a lot of similarities between
him and Rick throughout the Walking
Dead's run Negan eventually went on a
Redemption Arc Morgan told Men's Journal
Negan has become such an important part
of my life it'd be hard to make a clean
cut and walk away unless they just want
to kill me just a knife in the back and
maybe that's what needs to be done learn
for me to walk away from this guy fair
enough actors can never get too
comfortable as a cast member on an
apocalyptic zombie show Jeffrey Dean
Morgan understood that all too well as
he knew he could be killed after Walking
Dead at any moment speaking about when
he first went to Georgia to film Morgan
told the New York Times that he had a
conversation with showrunner Angela k
and said I had a three-year deal
initially I remember asking Angela
should I buy a house and she was like eh
and I was like well that's it I'm dead
Morgan never got a around to buying a
home in Georgia his wife Hillary Burton
told interview magazine in 2021 that to
keep the cast safe from filming her
guest episode during the covid pandemic
production had the cast quarantined in
Alexandria the neighborhood where the
AMC show was being filmed Burton added
we lived in Rick Grim's house there were
bullet holes in my child's closet door
Burton told interview magazine that
living on set during covid was a bizarre
experience saying we were living in a
real Apocalypse in the real world living
in a rented house in a fake apocalypse
and filming the beginning of a pandemic
despite filming The Walking Dead in
Georgia Morgan has remained committed to
his children going to a normal school
and living a life not regulated on a TV
set he and his wife own Mischief Farm in
Hudson Valley New York where the family
normally lives if Jeffrey Dean Morgan
hadn't already felt like the cast of The
Walking Dead with family weathering Kobe
together cemented the bond the cast and
crew already shared season 11 was shot
digitally instead of using film and
their production hired an army medic and
infectious disease specialist as a
safety precaution according to Insider
Morgan told deadline that during Co the
cast and crew were the only people who
could spend time together without extra
safety precautions he explained we
really leaned on each other it was hard
on us too and thank God we had each
other in an interview with geojournal
Morgan said that the show had a familiar
atmosphere sharing that co-star Norman
readers is known to his children as
Uncle Norman after The Walking Dead
wrapped Morgan was emotional about
watching the series finale he told
deadline it's weird I haven't been able
to watch the finale because there is a
finality to it that I don't think I'm
ready to deal with yet Morgan admitted
he hadn't actually watched the last four
episodes of the series he said I just
haven't wanted to watch them I think I
just needed to be in a mood Morgan
admitted to deadline that despite being
very excited about getting to continue
playing Negan in a spin-off series he
still misses the unique situation of the
original show saying I missed the show I
missed that crew and when I say crew I
mean the cast and the actual Crew The
Walking Dead spin off dead City picks up
a a couple of years after the events of
The Walking Dead finale it follows
Maggie played by Lauren Cohan and Negan
as a journey to Manhattan Morgan told
the New York Times when I found out the
show was ending I was like okay I did my
bit I'm proud of the work I did but AMC
floated the idea of a spin-off to him
and Morgan was all ears considering the
actor's attachment to Negan it isn't an
enormous surprise that he jumped at the
chance to apprise the role before the
show's Premiere Morgan told geojournal
that the shooting location was a
motivating factor in his decision saying
the fact that I get to be home played a
big part in making this decision really
easy for me Morgan admitted he couldn't
wait to see the zombie apocalypse in New
York City the actors told Entertainment
Weekly that he contemplated walking away
when the original Walking Dead ended but
decided to return due to the story being
good and wortht telling why I going to
help
you because you owe me I owe you right
what happens when a mega popular TV show
gets not just one but several spin-offs
criticism of course some fans of The
Walking Dead were upset when
announcements of the upcoming spin-off
series spoiled who would survive the
last season Morgan joined the chorus
himself speaking out about how AMC
announced dead City and other Series in
The Walking Dead franchise Morgan told
Entertainment Weekly that's not the way
we should have gone about it I would
have tried to go about it in a different
way but look that's above my pay grade
the actor told deadline that he got in a
bit of trouble for being so vocal about
AMC's error but he stood by his
statement he said if you had watched
this scene in the last episode of that
lineup imagine how much better that
scene would have been if you thought
Negan was going to die even with the
criticism Morgan holds a show close to
his heart he told Insider the journey
that I went on with my kids and my wife
was an amazing journey to be enveloped
by these people and the world because of
this show is something that will never
be duplicated
[Music]
ever